le monde à l'extérieur accroché à un
fil très fin, ce n'est qu'une question de temps
avant que le virus de la fusée éclaire le reste d'entre
nous, toute cette installation est conçue
pour vous garder en
sécurité s'ils l'emmenaient, ils cachent
quelque chose que ces gens ne sont pas ils disent
ils sont Thomas avez-vous vu que nous ne nous sommes jamais
échappés c'est méchant tout cela faisait
partie de leur jeu peut-être qu'ils
n'avaient qu'une question de quel côté êtes-vous sur
vos enfants ne durerait pas un jour dans
la brûlure
quelque chose à l'intérieur de nous que nous pourrions
vouloir  donc nous ne pouvons pas les laisser nous trouver
vous n'êtes pas obligés de venir avec moi Je
sais que nous pouvons faire en sorte que
personne ne sorte du Scorch depuis
longtemps
tous ces enfants qui ont été laissés derrière Je
ne veux pas finir  comme ça
bonjour Thomas tu me connais beaucoup de nos
amis sont morts pour que nous allions aussi loin donc
nous ne pouvons pas
abandonner c'est à propos de tout le monde que Wicked a déjà
pris ils ne s'arrêteront jamais alors je vais les
arrêter
n'est-ce pas  Je veux savoir pourquoi tout
cela s'est passé,
tu es si proche de la vérité